je suis ravie de vous saluer à nouveau à
Kiev et aujourd'hui le sujet clé était
le sujet des similacres des référendum
que la Russie organise sur les
territoires
Ukrainiens qu'elle a occupé et les
intentions de la Russie d'annexer ces
territoire la position de l'Ukraine et
de la France et commune il s'agit d'une
mise en scène d'un spectacle
de Poutine il est très mal mise en scène
ceci n'a aucune conséquence
c'est l'agression de la Russie contre le
crâne donc ces actes et ses décisions de
Poutine n'auront aucune influence sur la
politique la diplomatie et les actions
ukrainiennes sur le champ de bataille
constamment par ses actes quel
n'aspirent pas à la paix ni à la
solution diplomatique au conflit je
profite de l'occasion pour m'adresser à
tous les pays qui
se trouve à différents endroits du monde
et qui soulignait l'importance des
négociations qui insistaient sur les
négociations qui proposaient leur
service de médiation entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine et bien la Russie ne veut pas
de négociation du tout arrêter donc de
jouer à ce jeu
et
faites ce qu'il est nécessaire
aujourd'hui le plus important c'est
d'aider l'Ukraine et non pas d'éviter
ses actions en mettant un masque de
négociateur malheureusement le temps des
négociations n'est pas encore arrivé à
cause de la position de la Fédération de
Russie je profite de l'occasion pour
rappeler les paroles du président Macron
quand il s'est adressé à l'Assemblée
générale des Nations Unies en parlant
des et pays soi-disant neutres qui
pensent qu'ils peuvent rester à de côté
et attendre non ce ne sera pas possible
d'attendre il faudra prendre position et
position de justice et de vérité
et je suis reconnaissant gouvernement
français et à Madame Catherine Colonna
pour ce tien accordé à l'Ukraine dans
tout les points de l'ordre du jour
Catherine a dirigé brillamment la
réunion du Conseil de sécurité à New
York qui avait abordé la question de
l'impunité et la lutte contre la dignité
et la nécessité
pour la réussite de rendre des comptes
de ce qu'elle a fait en Ukraine nous
nous ressentons le soutien de la France
tous les jours surtout les niveaux et
notamment l'aide politique et militaire
aujourd'hui nous avons fait un pas en
avant en ce qui concerne les questions
de fourniture à l'Ukraine de nouveau
système d'armes César système
d'artillerie qui ont trouvé leur
efficacité sur le champ de bataille je
n'ai aucun doute que nos efforts communs
permettront
aboutir ce contrat et ceci a renforcera
les défenses ukrainiennes la France joue
un rôle très important dans les
questions de sécurité nucléaire et à
porte une attention toute particulière à
la centrale
nucléaire de zapparija nous avons donc
abordé cette question et nous avons
abordé la question de sécurité
alimentaire mondiale notre agenda est
bien chargé et je remercie madame à
Catherine Colonna d'être venu à Kiev
tout de suite après la fin de la
session de l'Assemblée Générale à New
York
c'est très important de voir Catherine à
Kiev maintenant et je l'apprécie
beaucoup et je vous passe la parole
nous y sommes bonjour à tous et à tous
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre cher
métro de ton accueil toujours chaleureux
et permettez-moi d'ajouter que je suis
heureuse d'être de nouveau à
nous avons eu un échange
sérieux et confiant comme toujours
poursuivant les conversations que nous
avons eu la semaine dernière à New York
puisque nous nous sommes vus au moins
deux fois je crois en marge de
l'Assemblée générale des Nations Unies
et au Conseil de sécurité je précise que
je me suis entretenu ce matin avec le
procureur général monsieur costine et je
serai reçu un peu plus tard par le
président zellinski
c'est la troisième fois que je me rends
à Kiev depuis ma prise de fonction la
dernière fois c'était aux côtés du
Président de la République le 16 juin
président qui était accompagné du
chancelier allemand du président du
Conseil des ministres italiens et du
président roumain
et cette fois en effet ma visite se
tient peu après la réunion du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies que nous
avons organisé sous président françaises
jeudi à New York
et qui a signé je crois l'isolement de
la Russie
peut avant le départ du bateau un bateau
pour l'Ukraine
qui est un bateau à fouetté par la
France chargé de c'est la plus grosse
opération d'aide humanitaire que nous
menons chargée de plus de 1000 tonnes de
fret
humanitaires pour la reconstruction et
en équipant aussi de sécurité civile et
j'y serai demain soir
et vivre qui se tient aussi au moment où
une nouvelle mission de gendarme
enquêteur vient d'arriver pour aider
enquêter sur les crimes commis à Isio
mais dans la région de quartier je crois
que ça illustre bien trois volets de
l'action de la France
l'action politique et diplomatique bien
sûr l'action humanitaire et de
reconstruction je verrai l'une de ces
opérations cet après-midi et puis la
lutte contre l'impunité
au cours des derniers mois parmi témoins
de retracer quelques éléments
devant vous l'Ukraine a réussi
à résister à l'armée russe dans le tomba
c'est la même entamé une
contre-offensive dont les résultats sont
nets dans la région de kerkiv et qui
progresse également sur le franc sud
elle a obtenu le statut de candidat à
l'Union européenne en faveur duquel la
France présidente en exercice du Conseil
de l'Union européenne c'était forcément
mobilisé et je suis heureuse de ce
résultat et puis elle a desserré le
blocus
imposé par la Russie en commençant à
pouvoir exporter ces céréales à la fois
par la mer Noire et par la voie
terrestre et fluviale sur l'ouest du
continent dans le cadre de l'initiative
européenne qu'on appelle les corridors
de la solidarité et qui ont été
remarquablement efficaces puisque plus
de 10 millions de tonnes ont déjà pu
être exportées
à ce propos je voudrais ajouter une
précision peut-être avez-vous entendu le
président de la République rebondir sur
l'initiative du président zellenski
d'offrir 50000 tonnes de céréales à la
Somalie et à l'Éthiopie je crois que
c'est un geste particulièrement fort de
la part d'un pays en guerre que d'offrir
des céréales à des pays qui en ont
besoin et je voudrais vous dire que la
France va contribuer à cet effort pour
couvrir les frais de transport et de
distribution de ces céréales vers la
Somalie à hauteur de 14 millions d'euros
je précise que l'Allemagne fait de même
pour ce qui concerne la livraison et la
distribution de céréales qui concernera
l'Éthiopie
ces résultats acquis depuis quelques
mois force l'admiration et je le dis non
sans ajouter que chacun mesure bien sûr
les souffrances
endurées par le peuple ukrainien depuis
maintenant 7 mois et donc cela va sans
dire ma présence aujourd'hui ma nouvelle
présence
signifie aussi que nous avons voulu de
façon visible
adressée une nouvelle fois un message
d'amitié et de soutien de la France à
l'Ukraine
la France chère de métro est à vos côtés
depuis le début de l'agression russe et
elle le sera jusqu'à ce que l'Ukraine
recouvre sa pleine souveraineté et son
intégrité territoriale et le restera
donc pendant cette phase dans laquelle
nous sommes mais aussi après la guerre
parce que je suis convaincu qu'il y aura
un après
le soutien que nous apportons est massif
il mobilise
toutes les composantes de l'État
français que ce soit en matière
humanitaire économique et financière
diplomatique aux militaires dans le
cadre d'une enveloppe qui est déjà de
plus de 2 milliards de dollars et ce
soutien je le répète il se poursuivra
dans la durée y compris pendant la phase
de reconstruction de l'Ukraine
sur le fond vous venez de le rappeler
monsieur le ministre cher de métro et le
président de la République a été tout à
fait clair à New York on s'adressant aux
États membres de la communauté
internationale
ils ont le choix simple aujourd'hui de
devoir choisir entre faire le choix de
la guerre ou faire le choix de la paix
et ne pas rester neutre on ne peut pas
rester notre
la France a fait son choix c'est celui
d'un refus du retour aux impérialismes
et aux colonies le refus d'un monde où
un chef d'État peut décider seul de
violer les principes fondamentaux de la
Charte des Nations Unies
de violer les règles les plus
élémentaires du droit international et
du droit humanitaire et de mener une
guerre
inutile illégale injuste de menacer les
fondements même de l'ordre international
basé sur des règles et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle ceci nous concerne
tous
ce que nous avons vu à New York le
ministre et moi-même c'est que la Russie
est de plus en plus isolée
personne ne s'est porté au Conseil de
sécurité au soutien de sa présentation
au demeurant
parfois étonnante le narratif qu'elle a
présenté est incohérent
il ne convainc personne
très honnêtement c'était même à se
demander si notre collègue russe croyait
véritablement aux paroles qu'il
prononçait
et je le redis personne au Conseil de
sécurité n'a pris la parole pour
soutenir la position de la Russie
parce que chacun voit que la Russie
s'enfonce dans une impasse militaire
vis-à-vis de la communauté
internationale et peut-être aussi
désormais vis-à-vis de sa propre
population
on le voit et ceci alors même que les
sanctions sans précédent que nous avons
adopté produire leurs effets et vont
produire leurs effets encore davantage
en gênant de plus en plus puisque c'est
leur objectif l'effort de guerre mené
par la Russie
alors vous le disiez jamais trop le
président russe s'est lancé dans une
rhétorique escalatatoire
en décrétant la mobilisation partielle
de la population russe une population
qui est à l'évidence ne le soutient plus
en annonçant l'organisation de
simulacre de référendum dans les régions
occupées où on adoptant une rhétorique
escalatoire sur la question nucléaire
tout ceci ne nous détournera pas ni de
nos principes ni de nos objectifs et je
veux redire aujourd'hui à Kiev ce que
nous avons dit à New York en marge des
réunions de l'assemblée générale et lors
de la réunion du Conseil de sécurité si
la Russie procède à l'organisation de
ces référendums illégaux et bien il y
aura des sanctions qui sont suivront ce
sera le cas de la part de l'Union
européenne avec le plein soutien de mon
pays
je vous disais que j'avais pu rencontrer
ce matin le procureur général à
l'occasion de l'arrivée de d'une
nouvelle équipe d'experts français
un volet important de notre action nous
en avons parlé à New York également
c'est la lutte contre la dignité
des crimes qui ont été commis et qui
sont commis
en présidence du Conseil de sécurité la
France a tenu à organiser une réunion
spécifique qui était la première réunion
un niveau ministériel du Conseil de
sécurité depuis le 24 février
réunion spécifique portant sur la lutte
contre l'impudité avec le secrétaire
général des Nations unies les États
membres quelques pays invités et autour
de Monsieur Karim Kane le procureur
général de la CPI parce qu'il ne peut
pas y avoir de paix sans justice et je
veux le réaffirmer c'est une certitude
il n'y aura pas de paix sans justice la
justice doit passer alors nous avons
déjà contribué je pense en envoyant deux
missions d'enquêteurs spécialisées en
Ukraine au mois d'avril au mois de mai
jusqu'au mois de juin et nous venons
aujourd'hui d'accueillir avec le
procureur général une nouvelle mission
d'expert français de l'Institut de
recherche criminelle de la gendarmerie
nationale qui permettra d'identifier les
victimes et de collecter les preuves des
crimes graves commis is you
nos objectifs ce sont la défense de la
souveraineté et de l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Ukraine je l'ai dit
c'est également la sécurité du continent
européen et l'ordre international fondé
sur des règles et qui nous permet de
vivre en paix et en se respectant les
uns les autres
je vais évoquer à ce titre les graves
menaces qui pèsent sur les installations
nucléaires civiles
ukrainienne et notamment sur la centrale
de zaporigia
la sûreté et la sécurité de la centrale
de saporica est en jeu
l'occupation par les forces armées
russes de cette centrale fait peser un
grave risque une grave menace
d'accidents nucléaires et donc nous
sommes au soutien de la mission du
directeur général de l'IA monsieur
grossi nous avons pu tous ensemble faire
en sorte qu'une première mission se
rendre sur place mais pour éviter un
accident nucléaire il est désormais
essentiel de mettre en place la zone de
protection proposée par le directeur
général de l'agence avec un arrêt des
combats autour de la centrale et un
retrait des équipements militaires
russes nous soutenons pleinement ces
propositions nous sommes réunis avant
adopté à une dizaine de pays à New York
une déclaration au soutien de cette
action et c'est bien évidemment dois-je
le préciser
une première étape de façon à atteindre
l'objectif de la démilitarisation
voilà sur cette situation qui reste le
préoccupante et sur laquelle nous devons
continuer d'agir je m'arrête là mais je
voudrais
continuer simplement par une dernière
phrase pour souligner
l'importance les trois tests de nos
relations le soutien constant que nous
apportons et apporterons à l'Ukraine et
je le redis chardis métro au-delà de
cette phase très difficile d'aujourd'hui
nous sommes à vos côtés et la France est
votre ami
merci on a un très court question le
premier BFM
bonjour Benoît ballet BFM TV une
question pour madame la ministre Colona
vous avez évoqué des sanctions si la
Russie venait à reconnaître les
référendums présentés comme tel en tout
cas dans les régions aujourd'hui
occupées pouvez-vous préciser de quel
sanctions il s'agit qu'elles sont la
France envisage également l'Union
européenne s'il vous plaît bien sûr ces
sanctions sont prises comme les
précédentes dans un cadre européen il y
a déjà 6 trains de sanctions et puis en
exercice 7ème même si on le baptise
rarement 7e qui ont été adopté à
l'unanimité par les Européens nous avons
donc sans attendre la fin de ces pseudos
référendum engagé un travail entre
européen les consultations sont en cours
de façon à déboucher le plus rapidement
possible sur une nouvelle série de
sanctions elles seront très certainement
tout à la fois individuel pour cibler
les responsables de ces opérations
illégales et toucheront sans doute
d'autres secteurs qui n'étaient pas
encore sous sanctions et qui sont donc
appelés à le devenir
[Musique]
au ministre
ukrainien est-ce que il y aura un
huitième paquet de sanctions et
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre la réponse
la plus simple et la plus juste serait
oui
nous continuons de renforcer notre aide
militaire à l'Ukraine nous sommes pas
seuls à le faire mais nous le faisons et
nous le ferons nous en avons évidemment
parlé avec le ministre couliba comme
nous le faisons à peu près chaque fois
que nous nous parlons je ne vais pas
entrer dans les détails il en a donné
quelques-uns le reste est en cours mais
c'est en effet quelque chose que je peux
vous confirmer
[Musique]
donc voilà
huitième paquet de sanctions nous allons
voir
quelle est l'attitude sérieuse de
l'Union européenne vis-à-vis de ces
simulacres de référendum il ne sera pas
suffisant de mettre en place les
restrictions personnelles contre les
personnes qui a participé au organisme
on s'est référendum il ne sera pas
suffisant de mettre en place des mesures
économiques cosmétiques il faudra des
actes très sérieux qui pourrait porter
un coup à l'économie russe
[Musique]
ensuite
si cette réaction au simulacre de
référendum et faible
la Russie sera stimulée pour une
escalade futur et pour l'annexion des
territoires
par conséquent nous avons transmis nos
attentes nos partenaires à tous les
niveaux et l'Union européenne est en
train d'élaborer une nouvelle tranche de
sanction
j'ai parlé à mes collègues à New York
j'ai parlé également par téléphone à mes
collègues aujourd'hui j'ai parlé à
Catherine
et donc je peux répéter ce que j'ai dit
au collègue à New York et bien c'est que
les préoccupations et les sanctions
individuelles n'arrêteront pas
l'annexion il faut que les accessoir
soit beaucoup plus ferme
d'enquêteurs de la gendarmerie nationale
dans la région d'izio est-ce qu'on peut
en savoir un peu plus sur les moyens
déployés et puis est-ce qu'il est-ce
qu'il est prévu qu'ils aiment qu'ils
aillent à cause d'achat l'opan dans le
nord du pays ou un nouveau charnier a
été découvert
merci Madame ils viennent d'arriver ils
seront déployés demain il s'agit d'un
certain nombre de spécialistes qui
aideront la justice ukrainienne un
documenté les crimes
identifier les victimes je rappelle par
ailleurs de la France a offert un
laboratoire mobile ADN qui je crois bien
utile à l'Ukraine et qui pourraient être
utilisés ils seront déployés dans la
région de kerkiz et amener à travailler
pour le moment dans une première partie
de leur mission en tout cas qui est
d'une durée de 15 jours renouvelable
donc ils seront amenés dans cette
première partie à travailler sur les
crimes qui ont été commis à isomes
ensuite nous verrons c'est sont appelés
à rester